so
i know
guys
okay
upstairs
this
love today
so
all right
so
yes
all right
thank you
okay
hello
let me just double check
oh
are you guys gonna be playing some more
stuff
on facebook
36.
all right so let's swear
all right
um real quick
he's pretty straightforward
right
is
if there's anything out there
although frankly
yes
yeah okay well i'm going to focus on
questions
my life
okay
[Music]
okay
yes
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
like
[Music]
so
is
just new cameras
look like
oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey how are you
not
thank you all right
[Music]
okay
yes
well so far he's been defending what he
told bob we were saying that he did not
want to cause a panic and even today
asking why woodward did not release
these quotes sooner if he thought that
they were so damaging
to the president that's about the best
line of defense that you see
coming from white house aides so far who
did not know the president was going
down audio tapes
of his folks to vogue and also did not
know how extensively
he sat down with the famed journalist
and author for this book coming up
and even the vice president brooke
admitted today he did not know
that the president had sat down with the
lord 18 times he said he'd only seen him
in the white house once or twice he
didn't know that and the team of staff
said last night
he would not have recommended that the
president grant that level of access
to woodward and so we've seen a bit of a
blame game going on at the white house
yesterday in the immediate aftermath of
this book coming out the excerpts of it
being released on cnn and in the
washington post but really ultimately it
was the president who made the decision
to sit down with one word and he
has been minimizing the access that he
gave to woodward but we know brooke that
is extensive
that he gave bob wilder his cell phone
number he called him late at night
sometimes from the residence
to talk to him about these conversations
that he was having
with china's president with other world
leaders and all of this stuff
that is now in this book because the
president didn't think
it would be as damaging if he cooperated
and if he spoke to woodward
and of course we're seeing how what
would just use the president's own words
to reveal
what it was that he really thought about
friend of ours back in february and back
in march
in all of those months when he was
saying something very differently
publicly
peter should i put the box on or turn it
off
oh
um
appreciated
at 3 30.
okay um i see
is there any chance that it was um
coming into the door
for a while and then it just maybe
wasn't noticed because the seal
when it breaks basically everything out
there just comes right through it
so which which rooms exactly
are where the weather is
okay i don't know where your desk is i
know where your stuff is
okay so in the bedroom and by the front
door
oh okay all right um okay let me call
sophie and see
um what we can do about that um
definitely obviously
um mop up with with the water uh
but maybe take some pictures if you if
if you already mopped it up that's fine
too
i don't i've never had water in that
room so i'm not sure exactly where it's
coming in from
does it look like it's coming from uh
where the pest control person put the
aluminum
oh okay all right um
so where exactly is the desk in the room
okay so basically like if the street was
north is it east south or what
west okay
all right um is it is it
are the walls are their walls dry
okay um
where
okay um the couch is in the middle of
the room right
okay um all right
okay so i honestly don't
know what exactly that means
but does it look like it's coming from
upstairs or if it's coming from the
ground
okay yeah it's flash flooding so
yeah geez i'm not sure okay um
i guess i mean let me talk to sophie and
see what she wants to do
it's hard for me to say because i'm not
there um if i was home i would go have a
look but maybe that's what she wants to
do
so i'm at work let me give her a call
all right okay thanks
what
so
what's up
um
right
uh
oh
um
all right
okay
okay
oh okay
okay
um
foreign
two minute warning
all right
so
so
so
okay
thank you very much wow we have some
big ones today this is a room loaded up
wow paula reed jonathan carl
phil rucker hi phil how are you
caitlin we've got the all-stars a lot of
all-stars today
youtube you too
that's good well that's fine
thank you very much in the past four
months we've added 10.6 million jobs
including 643 manufacturing jobs and
658 000 construction jobs as far
beyond expectations we've experienced
the smallest contraction
of any western nation meaning we've been
affected less than any other nation
western nation and probably almost i
think you can put us in
i just saw some numbers i think you can
put us into just about any category
anywhere
and the fastest recovery by far and
that's anywhere nobody's recovered like
we're recovering
if we followed joe biden's strategy we'd
shut down the entire country after just
having
set records on growth and we also did
have tremendous retail growth as you
probably noticed
we're witnessing the fastest labor
market recovery from
an economic crisis in our history by
contrast the
obama biden administration had the
slowest weakest and worst recovery in
american history
as you know we continue to make progress
in our fight against the china virus
new weekly cases have declined by 44
percent since july
deaths declined by 20 compared to just
last week
it's going down very rapidly really
rapidly
this is in contrast to nations in the
european union
which have recently experienced a sharp
increase in cases
they're having a very big spike over
there we're we're hopefully
beyond our spike we'll see but we're
doing very well all over our country
in the past five weeks per capita cases
doubled in france
surged to over 300 percent in spain
which i've been hearing about and
speaking to
some of the leaders of spain and they
are having a hard time
and increased more than 400 percent in
italy again
and as you remember i stopped i put a
ban on people coming in from
europe after the ban i imposed on china
wuhan
but because of wuhan primarily because
that area was very
infected we we also put a ban on
europe so spain is
being heavily impacted france and 400
percent in italy
yesterday european nations experienced
50 more deaths
than the united states and you don't
hear these things you don't hear these
statistics but the united states has
done really well
very proud of everybody that worked on
this
and i really do believe we're rounding
the corner and the vaccines are right
there but
even not even discussing vaccines and
not discussing therapeutics we're
rounding the corner
we already have therapeutics out there
by the way which are having obviously a
very big impact
because you look at that you look at the
the way people are recovering
it's so much better than in the past
before we knew about the disease and had
anything to fight the disease
on schools as part of our science-based
approach
we want schools to safely
open and stay open children are
extremely low risk of
complications from the virus less than
0.2
0.2 of the
coronavirus deaths have occurred and
those under the age of 25
and most had underlying conditions where
there was a problem
there's no substitute for in-person
learning according to a recent study
student progress in math
decreased by half and using online
education compared to
in-person or campus education so online
we think of
so many things online and how great it
is there's nothing like being in the
classroom that's what we've learned from
this whole
ordeal according to the cdc school
closures disproportionately harm
low-income and minority children as well
as those with disabilities
and i think you see some slides behind
me that are
very new very current
it's also crucial for colleges and
universities
to stay open and we hope that they do
indeed stay open
we want to see big ten football we hope
it's coming back we have a lot of the
uh colleges that we're talking about
they want to come back we hope that
michigan agrees we hope that and i know
the governor will have a lot to say
about it we hope she
approves it but uh we have a couple that
maryland's another one
we hope the governor puts a little
pressure on so that we can have it but
i have a feeling they may do it they may
do it without
having everybody but i think they're
going to have maybe
michigan maybe maryland we have a couple
of of uh
states that might not participate
but people are working very very hard to
get big ten football back and i'm
pushing it
and it'll be a great thing for our
country and uh the players
and the coaches want to do it really
badly the players are missing they only
have so many years of this and the
players are missing a big opportunity
including the chance in some of the
cases
they have some of the best players
college players in our country
and they want to get into the nfl and
they want to make money in the nfl and
they're not going to be able to do that
too easy if
you don't get to see them play it's much
safer for students to live on campus at
low-risk young people would rather than
uh the alternative it's the alternative
is no good
then going home spreading the virus to
high-risk americans
it's they want to be on campus they want
to go back to school and the parents
want them back in school maybe
more so than they want to be back in
school and they want to back safely and
they want to go back safely but they
have to go back based on
the recent data from more than 20
colleges not a single student who tested
positive for the virus has been
hospitalized
so that's a lot of people that's a lot
of students not one
has been hospitalized as we continue to
follow the science-based approach to
protect our people and vanquish the
virus joe biden continues to use the
pandemic
for political gain every time i see him
he starts talking about their pandemic
he's reading an offer teleprompter i'm
not allowed to use a teleprompter why
is that phil they ask questions and he
starts reading the teleprompter
he says move the teleprompter a little
bit closer please
i don't know i think if i did that i'd
be in big trouble i think that would be
that would be the story of the year when
i took early action in january to ban
the travel
and all travel to and from china
the democrats and biden in particular
called it
xenophobic you remember that joe was
willing to sacrifice american lives to
placate the radical left
open border extremists and we saved
tens of thousands of lives probably
hundreds of thousands of lives and we
saved millions of lives by
uh doing the closing and now the opening
the way we did it
joe's decision to publicly attack the
china ban proved he lacks the
character or intelligence or instinct to
do what is
right now biden's launched a public
campaign against the vaccine which is so
bad
because we have some vaccines coming
that are incredible
scott was telling me about some of the
things that are happening and it's very
exciting scott thank you for being here
but you don't want to have anything
having to do with the political
purposes being an anti-vaxxer
you don't want to be talking about the
vaccines in a negative way especially
when you see the statistics that
we're starting to see they're incredible
actually
biden's perfectly happy to endanger the
lives of
other people by doing something that he
thinks is going to help him politically
because his polls are getting very bad
they're getting very shaky
this was an election that was going to
be very easy very quick and then the
china virus came in and
i had to go back to work politically
unfortunately i had to devote more time
politically than
the other things we do which are very
important for our country but i had to
go back to work and
it looks like uh looks like we're going
up very rapidly
more rapidly than the media wants to
admit and biden's had to go out he's
gotten out of his basement and he's
working let's see what happens but we've
got to talk about how great these
vaccines are if in fact they're great
and i think you're going to see numbers
that are going to be very very
impressive
the approach to the virus is a very
unscientific blanket locked down by the
democrats that's what they're
talking about which takes all of these
incredible statistics records
and it throws them out the window now
they did say it would be based on
the recommendation of the experts but
you know whether expert or not
we're not doing any more shutdowns we
did the shutdown
and now we're doing the opening and
there won't be any more shutdowns
there could be a little section a small
section we have a breakout but we're not
talking about shutdowns like
they were talking about depending on
experts we're not going to be doing that
the uh swine flu was a disaster you
remember when
not nearly as deadly not a not the same
world but
when joe biden was vice president
his failed approach to the swine flu
was disastrous he called it he called it
n1h1 it's actually h1n1 you know you
remember the h comes before the
end so it's sort of easy to remember
right but joe always calls it the
opposite way but it was
call it the swine flu it was disastrous
and his own chief of staff said that
when biden helped
manage the swine flu in 2009
they quote did everything possible
wrong and 60 million americans got
h1n1 in that period of time this is a
quote from his chief of staff
and it's just purely a fortuity
that this isn't one of the great mass
casualties of events
it had nothing to do with us doing
anything right because we did everything
wrong it was a disaster
it was a disaster and now he's telling
us
he had a manner he can't manage himself
270 000 americans were hospitalized
during
this attack the outbreak was so rampant
that the obama administration
told states to stop testing we don't
want any tests because they don't want
to show
all of the things that show by the way
we're setting a record on testing
our testing is at a level that nobody's
ever seen before we're
substantially greater than the second
country which is india by the way
which has 1.5 billion people but we're
50 million tests ahead 50 million ahead
and they ordered the cdg to stop
counting tests
and stop counting cases and then left us
a depleted stockpile which is what i
inherited i inherited a depleted
a very badly depleted stock well in
other words biden's
record demonstrates that if he had been
in charge of this very serious
highly highly contagious epidemic or
pandemic
the china virus countless more americans
would have died
and if we didn't do what we did and i
say it all the time now because
the media likes to belittle what we've
done has been incredible now you can
look at europe and you can look at other
places and you can start comparing
biden is weak on china yesterday it was
revealed that
a fund partly owned by joe biden's son
hunter
facilitated the sale of a michigan auto
parts producer to a leading chinese
military defense contractor you don't
want to write about that do you
biden spend his entire career selling
michigan jobs to china
now the biden family is selling out our
country directly to the chinese military
which has to do with this company that
hunter here we go with hunter again he
didn't have a job now all of a sudden
he's selling
companies from michigan to china china's
military got american manufacturing jobs
and
the biden family got paid a lot of money
and i said if joe biden
ever got elected china will own
america he will they will own america
finally i can announce with great pride
that secretary of state mike pompeo will
be
departing this evening on a historic
trip to duha
that's qatar for the beginning of intra
afghan peace negotiations we've been
negotiating with them for quite some
time
getting along with them moved a lot of
soldiers out i got a report this morning
that there's been nobody
killed in afghanistan since early
february
it's a long time there's been no deaths
no problems
and a lot of progress is being made in
afghanistan but
we'll be down to 4 000 soldiers in a
very short period of time likewise iraq
will be down to about 2 000 soldiers in
a very short period of time
and in syria for the most part we're out
other than we kept the oil
uh as we have soldiers guarding the oil
not too many i think
small number but they're guarding the
oil
and we're helping the kurds and we're
making their lives
much more pleasant uh because of the
fact that we have the oil
so we're pretty much out of syria
we're pretty much out of iraq and we're
down to the smallest force that
we've had in uh we'll be very shortly
down to that number
in afghanistan the negotiations are a
result of a bold diplomatic effort
one part of my administration in recent
months and years the united states will
play an important role in bringing the
parties together
to end the decades-long war it's been
going on for almost 20 years
long before i got involved i can tell
you that
and had they not been wasting our time
with all of the
phony witch hunts and all of the things
we probably could have done this even
faster
but a lot of time had to be spent wasted
like that
but the parties are together right now
and we're
negotiating and we're really making
tremendous progress
next week at the white house we'll be
having a signing between
uae and israel and we could have another
country added into that and i will tell
you countries are lining up that want to
go into it
as you know uh uae is headed by a very
very highly respected
gentleman and respected by everybody
and he's a warrior too he's a great
warrior
and muhammad's very excited about this
and
you'll be hearing other countries coming
in over a relatively short period of
time
and you could have peace in the middle
east i think what ultimately will happen
is you're going to have
quite a few countries come in the big
ones are going to be coming in i spoke
to
the king of saudi arabia so we're
talking we're starting we just started
the dialogue
and you'll have them come in and i think
two things are going to happen iran will
if we win the election iran will come
and sign a
deal with us very very rapidly within
the first
i would say week but let's give
ourselves a month because their
gdp went down 25 which is like an
unheard of number
and they'd like to be able to get back
to having a successful country again
so i think that'll happen and i think
very importantly uh
the palestinians will get back into
the fold and when they see all of these
countries that frankly have been
supporters of the palestinians very big
supporters and certainly financial
supporters
as you know we used to pay the
palestinians 750
million dollars a year and i ended that
some time ago on the basis that they
didn't seem to want to make peace
and uh we'll think about it once
we have a deal but i've ended that quite
a while ago
i'm frankly surprised they haven't been
to the table
uh earlier but this is the best way this
is a way that's going to be great this
can really bring the middle east
together
and again since february we haven't had
a death in afghanistan which is
that's a record for many years not a
death
and we're getting along very very well
with the taliban and very well with
afghanistan and its uh representatives
and we'll see how it all goes it's a
negotiation but
secretary of state mike pompeo will be
departing uh
in a little while so i think that's very
exciting news
and a lot of people thought that my
natural instinct is war no my
natural instinct is actually peace when
we were on the debate stage people used
to say will it be one week or two weeks
before
president trump gets into a war but
that's not i did rebuild our military
we have a military that two and a half
trillion dollars new
jets and rockets and tanks and
ships and a lot of things we have we
have the newest best military we've ever
had so
uh hopefully we won't have to use it our
nuclear program has been put into gear
like never before and in particular
hopefully
we won't have to use that because that's
a whole new level
of destruction and we never want to just
have to pray to god we never have to use
that
all right please john thank you mr
president
why did you lie to the american people
and why should we trust what you have to
say
terrible question and the phraseology i
didn't lie
what i said is we have to be calm we
can't be panicked
uh i knew that the tapes were
these were a series of phone calls that
we had mostly phone calls
and uh bob woodward is somebody that
i respect just from hearing the name for
many many years
not knowing too much about his work not
caring about his work
but i thought it would be interesting to
talk to him for
a period of you know calls so we did
that
i don't know if it's going to be i don't
even know if the book is good or bad
but certainly if he thought that was a
bad statement
he would have reported it because he
thinks that you know you don't want to
have anybody that
is going to suffer medically because of
some fact and he didn't report it
because he didn't think it was bad
nobody thought it was wait a minute
women and your question the way you
phrase that is such a disgrace it's a
disgrace to abc television network it's
a disgrace to your employer
and that's the answer are you ready
because
i i love
and then you went out and told the
american public that this was just like
the flu
you told everybody else something else
no and five times right
five times you ever hear the expression
five times we've had flu years where we
lost 100 000 people
the flu is a very serious problem for
this country also
and we've been losing them scott what
kind of a number have we lost over the
years with flu
into the hundreds of thousands well i
mean the
last five years have been something like
35 to 80 000
per year every year even with antiviral
drugs and even with flu is a very
serious problem also
but just saying this is worse than the
most deadlier than the most strenuous
flu okay
and then you went out and said it's just
like the flu
what i went out and said is very simple
listen what i went out and said
is very simple i want to show a level of
confidence and i want to show
strength as a leader and i want to show
that our country is going to be fine one
way or the other
whether we lose one person we shouldn't
lose any because this shouldn't have
happened this is china's fault this is
nobody's fault but china china should
not have allowed it to happen
whether you have a one person 180 000
people
or two and a half or three million
people
which it could have been very seriously
if we didn't make the moves
and when you look at the opposition
where they said oh why did he put the
ban on
dr fauci said we saved hundreds of
thousands of lives by putting the ban on
china and then ultimately putting the
ban on
europe there was no lie here what we're
doing is we're leading and we're leading
in a proper way
and if frankly somebody else was leading
it they wouldn't have closed it
if you look at nancy pelosi you look at
cuomo you look at de blasio
you look at biden months later they said
there's no problem
they're talking about me months later
and before any statement was made you
have to remember i put the ban on china
so obviously outwardly i said it's a
very serious problem
and it's always a serious problem that
doesn't mean i'm going to jump up and
down in the air and start saying people
are going to die people are going to die
no
no i'm not going to do that we're going
to get through this and we're right now
i hope
really think we're going to we're
rounding the final turn
and a lot of good things are happening
with vaccines and with therapeutics
but there's no lying and the way you ask
that question is very disgraceful
go ahead please go ahead yeah
i think we did a great job and the
people that did such
are generals our admirals mike pence all
of the people
that have worked so hard and now dr
atlas
and all of them dr fauci dr burks
they should be respected for the job
they've done so you walk down you have
it
you won't downplay it again because you
said you downplayed it that's what you
told me all i'm doing is
no i don't want to jump up and down and
start screaming death
death because that's not what it's about
we have to lead a country we're leading
a
great country and we're doing a great
job and the people that have done such a
good job
should be given the kind of credit that
they deserve we possibly have done the
best jobs
when you start looking at what we're
doing with the vaccines and therapeutics
and ventilators
we had no ventilators john we make
thousands of ventilators now a month
and we're supplying them to the whole
world the job we've done is the best job
and don't give me any credit give the
people that have done this
the credit they've done a great job yeah
phil go ahead yeah mr president you
talked about the need to stay calm
and not just and scare people
a lot of other world leaders were calm
german chancellor angela merkel was very
calm as she presented information to the
german people
so that they could stay safe and protect
their families so why is you as
president of the united states
did you not level with the american
people did you not share the information
that you knew at the time in real life
but if you look at the european union
right now they're having breakouts like
you've never seen before
and frankly their numbers are a level
that are much worse than the numbers
here we are we have done
we have phil we have done much much
better than the european
union i just read you numbers that are
not good on their behalf and that are
very good at ours and we have rounded
the final turn
and we have we we're going to have
vaccines very soon maybe
much sooner than you think listen maybe
much sooner than you think
but we have done a phenomenal job and
the people that have done this job
including the american public that's had
to put up with a lot
with the lockdowns and all of the things
that they had to do they have to be
given credit they have to be giving
credit
for the deadly virus you knew it was
airborne you knew on february 7th you
told bob woodward how it transferred
from person to person in the air how
deadly it was
why did you not come to the podium well
let me ask you this if bob woodward
thought that was bad because this is
stuff that everyone knew
there's a report that i have here
someplace
where china said it was airborne earlier
than the statements i made
people knew it was airborne this was
nothing this was no big when i say it
was airborne
everybody knew it was airborne this was
no big thing in february
read the reports china came out with a
statement that it was an
airborne disease i heard it was an
airborne disease i assumed it early on
the fact is there has to be a calmness
you don't want me jumping up and down
screaming there's going to be great
death there's going to
and really causing some very very
serious problems for the country
if bob woodward thought what i said was
bad then he should have immediately
right after i said it gone out to the
authorities so they can prepare and let
them know
but he didn't think it was bad and he
said he didn't think it was bad
he actually said he didn't think it was
bad the only one that said it was bad or
thinks it was bad were
the fake news media because they take it
and they try and put it a certain way
if bob woodward thought it was bad
then he should have immediately gone out
publicly
not wait four months you know he's had
that statement for four months maybe
five months he's had it for a long time
it was a series of taped interviews
mostly by telephone
quick ones not long ones quick ones and
it was i did it out of curiosity because
i do have respect and i want to see i
wonder whether or not somebody like that
can write good
i don't think he can but let's see what
happens thank you mr president
um we're just about 50 days out from the
election and we haven't seen a lot out
of the durham investigation yet
where is that and do you do you have
confidence in the investigation
well i can't tell you that yet i have to
see i'm not involved in it i purposely
stayed uninvolved i'm
i guess considered the chief law
enforcement officer of the country i
could be involved if i wanted to i
thought it would be
better if i wasn't i think it's better
if
our great attorney general handle it he
has durham who is a uh
very very respected man and we're going
to see what it is i can't tell you that
i can tell you this i can tell you this
they
uh they lied they
cheated they leaked
they got caught they spied on my
campaign
never in history has there been anything
like this
and i guarantee if the roles were
reversed and i was on the democrat side
people would have been in jail at the
very highest level
people would have been in jail for two
years already
nothing like this has ever happened and
the term would be for many many years
because it's treason and other words can
be used also
do you think there should be more
indictments as a part of this event i
think just on what i read in your
wonderful papers i think
and and see what you know just looking
at the media
not even what i know uh i think comey
is a disgrace to our country i think
strzok
who just wrote a book which is a total
fake uh
is a disgrace i think paige lisa page
his lover
is a disgrace to our country uh i think
that when you look at mccabe where his
wife got seven hundred thousand dollars
in campaign contributions
from hillary clinton right and then
hillary clinton is under investigation
and yet she paid the head of the fbi one
of the top people but actually the head
because he took over for
for the other guy who fortunately i
fired i made a good move when i fired
that was a smart move
because they were looking to take down
this administration duly elected
administration so i fired him that was a
great move when i fired him because
maybe if i didn't i wouldn't be here
talking to you as president
but when mccabe's wife gets 700 000
in campaign contributions when she was
running for whatever office she was
running from from
virginia and yet he's in charge of the
investigation of hillary clinton now he
says well i wasn't really in charge
of course he was a judge he was totally
in charge he knew exactly what was
going on these people got caught in
the probably the biggest political
scandal in the history of our country
they got caught now what the durham
report is going to say i can't tell you
but if they say half as much as i
already know just from
seeing it you know you have people i
watch some of the
shows i watch liz mcdonald she's
fantastic i watched
fox business i watched uh
lou dobbs last night sean hannity last
night
tucker last night laura
i watched uh fox and friends in the
morning you watching shows
uh you don't have to go too far into the
details they cover
things that are it's really an amazing
thing they got caught
in the biggest political scandal in the
history of our country
they were spying on their opponents
campaign
not only spying they were making up fake
dossiers you have the
dirty dossier they were making up the
dirty
it was all made up it was all fiction it
turned out to be fiction
and then they were using that in the
fisa courts this revered court
what's not so revered anymore because
when you look at what they did and how
they played it and they heard a lot of
people
general flynn is still being hurt and
he's being hurt very badly
he's a wonderful person i spoke to
general milley about general flynn two
weeks ago i said what do you think of
general flynn he said
he's a great soldier sir he's a
wonderful wonderful human being he's
been destroyed
he's been destroyed no i think that
this uh without knowing anything about
what durham is going to release the
durham report we'll call it
uh or maybe it's going to be more than a
report maybe it's going to be much more
than a report i don't know maybe it's a
report or maybe it's much more than that
but when i look at the the things that
everybody in this room knows just from
reading about it from yourselves back
and forth
i think it's a disgrace to our country
and i think if people
don't pay a very very substantial price
it'll happen again and this should never
ever happen to another president
thank you very much